candidat joli gâteau cette terre qui
s'en va toi jean van de rosieren
doucement slow libyen l'a bien les
bosses on regarde à droite c'est très
joli ce mercato et je dis ça je dis rien
du tout on grossit rice s'est cette fois
ci les six équipes misions à tous à
droite pour le revers va passer derrière
dedans je te remettes dessus
ce qui serait ce que trois oeuvres par
des jeux comme ce serait bien que je
pense qu'ils prennent du plaisir
j'ai eu du plaisir
godard mais bon ce rasta voilà d'être
jolie tout mon jeu en plus de voix que
york ou de sens
bon y'a rien de bon avec truc année de
quoi un boss du donjon sans faire le
point comme beaucoup de français
pas de bouton victoire à camper et cidre
et genre en ville dans le bétail pour
pas des trucs on s'est pas passé dans
les pattes afin dit il au chi pierre
chip au sol sur l'île de jolo dans le
groupe a c'est pas joli visage
tous reçoivent à part ça
eux ils disent que fatalement public
donc vive le vent bull à chaque round up
to see ok ok go to je laisse voler
pendant que tout contact claude
bourgault clauses n'ont aucun droit
l'hexagone à venir l'un envers l'autre
gauche cette victoire est volée
habitant au point d'être joué
nous y voilà ok le poids des paysages
autour là on diabolise nos lignes
d'attaqué
alors là pour cela il ajouté c'est
audrey joly a même acheté tous copains
web anti sel et qui trop dangereux dans
la basilique à l'hélico qui font leur
fin et c'est beau c'est au sein du rugby
alors de les attendre
la gappe sous peu
oui mais voilà on est allé tourner en
parlera avec un peu jour le bac
la région compte neuf
en fait
comment ne rien formidable parlera dans
la plupart c'est comme des ambiances
haut à gauche je lis avec le contre-jour
écart mais la caméra vers la gauche a
peut-être un peu contre jour avec le lac
place est assez joli corps doit plutôt à
gauche encore peut-être le petit globe
de 2,5 le chercher et je lui parle un
peu ce paysage
le lac et les petites maisons devant le
jury sera aussi élaborée